boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on sockin we
are at Indy BIOS demo day number eight
we are now seeing down with Matt Gibson
hello hello thanks so much for coming on
really appreciate it ours and you just
did super well giving your pitch with
new culture
thank you very excited to explain to
people what is new culture what do you
guys work on so in a nutshell we're
making cow cheese without the cow now
what does that mean it means that we're
taking dairy proteins which are
responsible for the best traits about
dairy cheese and we're growing them with
microbes what that means is that we
don't have to use a cow and any of our
cheese making process so our cheese
becomes more sustainable healthier and
more ethical dairy proteins with
microbes yes how do we do this very good
question
so in a very simple way we take the gene
that encodes the protein that we want so
we want casein proteins which are the
most predominant protein and cheese and
we take that gene and we put it inside a
microbe now all that gene does is this
instructs the microbe to produce this
protein as casein protein and which
microbe we can't say that right now ok
so this is the proprietary this is part
of a prize for years ok so so a micro a
micro a food-grade microbe yep an energy
in the casein producing gene into the
gene inside and all we need to do from
there is grow it and a fermentation tank
and as it grows a big and secreting out
our gene of choice I mean sorry our
protein of choice and it's a matter of
just clicking the protein adding some
plant-based fans some plant-based sugars
and making a milk a sort of proto milk
they would just take through the
cheese-making process so we acidify it
then we add air in it so coagulate it
and form curd and we make delicious
mozzarella which is our first cheese
product from there you have a video of
you guys pulling up Arthur Arthur oh yes
great because usually the the vegan
cheese lines are have really big
struggle with you with the melting
process and stretching let's let's jump
back into the the process so okay so so
we have a microbe that has the casing
producing gene inside of it
grown in a bioreactor yes now does the
microbe itself end up replicating and
yes and so then that it ends up
replicating Plus then it produces casein
as well yes so there's two ways you can
do it one way is where we continuously
the microbe continuously produces the
gene as it grows so as soon as we put in
the bioreactor it starts producing the
gene I mean sorry the protein and it
just continues producing protein as it
as it grows and fills the bioreactor
the other way to do it is to just grow
your microbe as much as possible so it's
very dense and so the bioreactor and
then induce it to pump out your protein
to begin producing and pumping out your
protein so there's two ways you can do
it the first ways but can be a bit more
difficult because if the protein that
you want is quite toxic to the microbe
because it's not a natural protein it
makes us then it's a lot tougher to do
it continuously constitutive expression
is what it's called
so we're using more inducible expression
okay and then so then you're making it
so that the microbe grows larger and
then makes it so that these pro to the
proteins that it creates are larger then
no so so sorry yes or I'll clarify that
so the all we want to do is we take our
by rector and we want to fill it with as
much microbes as possible in a sense it
we put on my curb in there and it just
begins multiplying yes so more and more
microbes are in the buyer - yes and the
more microbes we have the more protein
can be produced yes so we're gonna wait
until there's a lot of microbes in that
by rector and then induce protein
expression oh okay okay so okay got it
so tons and tons of microbes first then
induced the protein okay got it and then
and then you got to make sure that the
protein that is creating that it does
not kill the microbes that's part that's
well that's causation that's um the
other part of a constitutive expression
which is when they come constantly
producing protein as we're doing
inducible so we're introducing the
microbe to secrete protein when we want
we don't have to worry so much a bit of
the proteins toxic to the microbe oh so
you have to in you induce manually and
then it's produces the protein and then
you and then it doesn't again yeah then
you do induce it again so you're
agreeing yeah which
you can only really do it once but I'll
produce a lot of protein and from there
we harvest the protein and we make
cheese with it ok now now let's get into
the process you said you add fats and
sugars in plant-based FETs and
plant-based sugars so gonna be how does
this work
so yeah sure so one thing we
hypothesized when we came into nd bio
was do we actually need animal fats in
animal sugar ie lactose to make great
cheese the or do we just need the
protein and can we supplement defense
and the sugars of plant-based options
and it turns out you can so as I said in
the pitch we did a double blind taste
test
we used dairy proteins and plant-based
fats and sugars and the class couldn't
distinguish the difference between cows
with mozzarella and now mozzarella is
huge yeah and so really comprehensive
the protein and that allows us to open
up our cheese to lactose intolerant
people right because there's about 50
million electus and tolerant Americans
out there and even though lactose levels
and cheese are less than a milk it's
still there silk and ms cheese and so we
can simply replace the lactose with
another plant-based sugar with the fence
we can use list saturated fats as many
films and cheese and make sort of a
healthier cheese and the key thing as
well is that there's no cholesterol
because cholesterol comes from animal
that comes from animal products and so
our cheese will be cholesterol free no
cholesterol yeah and which plant-based
fats and sugars again so that's still
something we actually aerating
so there's a whole bit of reading and
playing with yes so there's a whole
different sort of multitude of vets and
sure as we can use from plants are ready
from for example fats from sunflower oil
coconut oil I'm just kind of standards
that you'll be used to noting that some
to extremely far out they're just very
typical plant-based fancy sugars okay
and soon okay again 50 million
lactose-intolerant in the United States
and then around the world it's it's it's
shocked me actually how many they were
I'm especially and
more Asian countries that's 2/3 or the
world edge that have lactose sensitivity
sensitivity yeah and so it's actually
because of course humans weren't
designed to continually drink milk after
being infant right where she developed
elect os-- tolerance from consistently
consuming theory and believe it or not
cheese was a big part of it because the
the pop the the popularity of cheese and
how people loved it and keep eating it
even though it made them sick early on
and never them to eventually develop a
lactose tolerance so cheese plays a big
role and sort of shaping really human
the course of human history from our
diet point of view yeah yeah and then so
now where is were things moving with new
culture then you have 500 samples here
yes four and then you are you looking to
take then the mozzarella and get it into
stores so yes so so it's those are proof
of concept cheese's because the thing
about microbial fermentation to make
proteins
is that as you'll probably hear from
other companies doing some of the things
making animal produce with microbes it
takes a lot to scale it up so it takes
it's going to take us three to four
years of scale scale it up okay so the
proven concept cheese's we have out
there are more of a formulation exercise
where we take proteins individual
proteins from cow's milk not our own
produced proteins because we don't
simply have enough of them to feed 500
people okay but they're the same
proteins we're making from our microbes
and we're simply saying look we can make
delicious cheese starting from pure pure
protein so we know the formulation we
know how to make great cheese from pure
protein now as we scale up we just need
to supplement the protein that we're
getting from cow's milk from our own
protein yes yes okay and then the ideas
that you're right they're even
potentially cheaper and yeah so we
should we should get to our this is
America by boat bring my New Zealand
sort of units here so it's about Quincy
$20 a kg in two thousand and or in four
years time around there Wow yeah for our
cheese which is tend to get too
competitive
fools and we're talking about fresh
mozzarella snot look desiccated
mozzarella that you had great on to a
pizza the fresh mozzarella you make by
hand it make a ball worth that's nice
and soft that can be very expensive and
so we get into price parity and four
years time yeah and then they blame
people around the world that are lactose
are - exactly yeah and natives important
it's not just a selectively intolerant
as people that very much care about
their health and so they don't need
cholesterol and what they eat no
drinking which is actually a big reason
why Platts plant-based milks are on the
rise and of course the conscious
consumers that yes hear a lot about
sustainability and one of the fastest
growing movements out there and of
course Biggers of vegetarians that you
know have been I mean I've been a vegan
for about 10 or 11 years and I've never
been a fan of vegan cheese to put it
lightly and so I'm one of my own target
customers like any standout and sort of
scratch my own edge here I really want a
good sustainable cheese and there's just
nothing out there and that's a problem
because cheese is one of those
unsustainable of all food products the
most unsustainable theory products and
we need a good cheese currently is
nothing out there that would enable
anyone to transition from theory cheese
to vegan cheese relatively easily and we
think that by me eating the cheese that
is created from from bacteria that you
guys make the new culture that that is
longitudinally if I do that for maybe
twenty thirty several years that I
should be fine we it's hard we don't
have the studies in place yeah do you
think that oh yeah
so of course so what's interesting about
cheese is that it's already comes or
there's already a GMO source ingredient
in there so 99% of cheeses are using a
enzyme called chromosomes and commerson
is where you add some milk to get it to
curd and then phonetic curd you make
cheese now chymosin is found in the
stomach's of many mammals and it used to
be scraped from the stomach's of calf's
so people no longer do that anymore
yeah and so they make chymosin using
microbes the same way we're making
proteins
oh wow and so they use get the microbe
they take the gene that encodes chymosin
put it in the microwave
get it to produce us enzyme then use it
and she's making so it's quite
interesting that all cheese already uses
GMO derived products interesting hmm
well you used to scrape it out of the
cow's stomach yeah because it's the
reason why it's the enzyme down there is
because when we consume milk for us to
sort of enable us to digest it
effectively we need to curl it and that
curls in our stomach and it's where the
enzymes enzymes there and the enzymes
currently being made by bacteria yes
interesting interesting okay so it just
seemed like we should be cool
longitudinally doing the stuff yes okay
and then again so you were raising money
that make the next steps to scale this
up that's the next big thing for you
guys yes
so we're raising 2.8 million and it's
really mostly for us to do a lot of
engineering of our microbe and what it
means is more or less turning our toyota
of a microbe into a Ferrari and really
giving it to pump out a lot of protein
and to grow in very dense conditions
because remember the more dense we can
make on microbes fit inside this
fermentation tank the more proteins we
can produce and so doing a lot of that
strain engineering and also beginning to
scale up so once we get our micro to
perform very well we can start looking
to scale it up to 30 liters in to 300
litres and then post seed onto series a
we'll look to get into so that in the
thousands in terms of leases of all
fermentation tanks nice okay cool yeah
like that the from the Toyota to the
Ferrari you have a microbe Capac
capability it's really awesome analogy
okay sweet I think this has been very
interesting talking to you about new
culture and that's your food yeah thank
you so much for coming on Matt really
don't worry cred to have crisis talk to
you thank you thank you and for all
those that watched let us know your
thoughts in the comments below about the
episode also do check out the links
below to new culture as well as indie
bio support awesome entrepreneurs
artists educators different scientists
around the world that you believe in the
New York communities support simulation
our links are below help us out as well
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thanks for tuning and we'll see you soon
peace thank you
that's a wrap Matt give